this dialysis center in eldamer in
Sudan's River Nile state is under
pressure it was built to treat local
patients with kidney failure but that
was before four months of fighting
changed everything in Sudan now more and
more patients from far away regions are
coming here seeking help
we were displaced from Khartoum because
of the war and the people here at the
center received us but lately there's
been a lot of issues there are no tubes
because of shortages so we hope the
Ministry of Health will provide some we
fled from Khartoum because the war has
made it impossible to get dialysis there
so we can't come here and face the same
issues
as the number of patients Rises staff
here are making do with whatever they
have there's a shortage of medical
supplies medicines and other crucial
life-saving equipment and for those with
renal failures the shortages can be
fatal Sudan's doctors Syndicate says
dozens of patients with renal failures
have died since the war started in April
we suffer greatly to the point that the
center went out of service due to
mismanagement by the state Ministry the
center is back but the threat for it to
go out of service is still there because
of the lack of the medical Necessities
for renal dialysis we as patients are
calling on organizations to stand by US
during this crisis that killed many
dialysis patients because of this war
The Syndicate has also warned that at
least 8 000 patients with kidney failure
may lose their lives in the coming weeks
and dialysis centers in some states May
cease to operate if the shortage of
medical supplies is not addressed
we lack the Necessities for dialysis and
urge for their provision as soon as
possible the first to be affected will
be the patient we have nothing to do but
to urge International Aid organizations
to provide them as soon as possible if
we don't have these Provisions soon the
center will not be able to carry out
dialysis because there are no
alternatives to dialysis medications
for now patients here continue to
receive treatment for their kidneys and
hope that supplies arrive soon to help
keep them alive HEPA Morgan Al Jazeera